so anyways somebody's having fun with
her they get wrong he says hey can i
stay the night here i'm like yeah yeah
sure you know at this point i'm like
okay what's this girl's attention as the
night progresses well she wasn't engaged
anymore and whatever happened fall
asleep and i wake up this phone call
tells me to be quiet it's her fiance
calling from minneapolis uh saying he
couldn't get a hold of her all night and
she's like honey i went to bed at 10 30
after the show where have you been i've
been worried sick and then she starts
giving him for going to strippers
accusing him of cheating and i'm like
what the hell was that so she gets a
call in the morning from her boyfriend
and she turns the table
tables around and accuses him of the
very thing that she was doing
absolutely
i always tell you guys when somebody
points the finger at you they've got
three fingers pointing back at
themselves okay question that always